to covet news cbs news has learned the
fda may authorize coveted booster shots
for every adult in america today from
both pfizer and moderna now this comes
as cases are unfortunately surging in
some parts of the country and this week
michigan hit its
highest daily case average since the
pandemic began and that's where we find
our lead national correspondent david
begno he is in ann arbor michigan david
i don't like the direction of this good
morning
good morning michigan is dealing with
its first flu outbreak as it pertains to
the covet surge what we heard from
health experts here in michigan
is what we've heard for the last several
months and it's not going to surprise
you
the covet surge is being driven largely
by people who are unvaccinated
it's a killing disease
and i've come close to it
mighty close
in royal oak michigan 73 year old twilla
harrelson has been hospitalized for two
months with covid19 despite the fact
that she is fully vaccinated if you're
not vaccinated out there you're flat out
you're a fool
because that's the worst thing
that you can do is get out and spread
this disease
michigan is also fighting its first flu
outbreak
dr david donaldson is the chief of
emergency medicine at beaumont hospital
in troy we're starting to see some of
the other viruses that we haven't seen
over the last year like rsv and
influenza and that is a big difference
as well
federal officials at the cdc are
investigating nearly 530 influenza cases
reported at the university of michigan
with 77 percent of them being among the
unvaccinated while 98 percent of their
population has been vaccinated against
covet 19 and yes there is a mandate only
about a third of the student body have
had the flu shot dr lindsey mortensen is
the university's medical director
is that due to vaccine hesitancy or
people just not making the time to get
it done there's vaccine fatigue and they
think that the coveted vaccine protects
against the flu virus which it doesn't
so i think there's a lot of work we can
do
to keep our campus educated
cbs news has learned that the fda is
planning to authorize both the pfizer
and moderna boosters at the same time
for adults so if you're six months out
from your second shot you could be good
for a booster shot as early as this
weekend have a good one
we are still in this fight against covet
david thank you so much